bienvenidos bueno acabamos de encontrar
que el tiempo total en el aire es de la
velocidad inicial entre 10 bueno ahora
queremos saber qué tan lejos llegó
tenemos que nuestra distancia en x voy a
cambiar al azul de lo que estamos
manejando nuestros datos en x nuestra
distancia en el eje x es igual a la
velocidad en el eje x por el tiempo que
bueno este caso es el tiempo que estuvo
en el aire y esto si lo sustituimos lo
que encontramos tenemos que nuestra
velocidad x
la velocidad inicial por la raíz de 3
entre 2 por el tiempo en el aire
que es nuestra velocidad
inicial entre 10
esto nos quedan como
velocidad inicial al cuadrado por raíz
de 3
entre 20
bueno recordamos que esta velocidad
promedio en realidad es una velocidad
constante ya que la velocidad en el
componente x no cambia porque no hay
bueno si es un objeto pequeño no va a
tener resistencia del aire y hacemos
también que no tiene ninguna fricción
bueno ahora también tenemos la distancia
en función de la velocidad inicial
si sabemos que queremos llegar
exactamente a 100 metros cuál va a ser
nuestra velocidad inicial bueno tenemos
que nuestra distancia a llegar es 100
metros y eso es igual a velocidad
inicial al cuadrado por la raíz cuadrada
de tres entre 20
y bueno despejamos
nuestra velocidad inicial al cuadrado es
igual a
en tren raíz de 3
y la velocidad que queremos obtenerlo es
nuestra velocidad inicial al cuadrado
nuestra velocidad inicial
va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de
todo esto
/ raíz de 3 y vamos a usar nuestra
calculadora para obtener estos valores
primero obtenemos la raíz de 3 es igual
a 1.73
entonces
vamos a hacerlo paso a paso
a raíz de 31 puntos 73 cierto
aproximadamente hacemos la división de
2000 entre 1.70 y 3
/
1.73 y nos quedan
1.156 si obtenemos la raíz cuadrada de
esto nos quedan aproximadamente
metros por segundo
esto me parece muy padre ya que podemos
usarlo suponiendo que nuestra velocidad
inicial es la misma y si queremos
cambiar la distancia bueno pues con esto
podemos calcular usando nuestras
funciones trigonométricas inversas
podemos calcular el ángulo exacto al que
debemos hacer disparo para dar con
nuestro objetivo y con esto terminamos
este vídeo nos vemos después